[Music]
okay okay this video is sponsored by
LastPass hey what's up guys I'm QB HD
here so Huawei's riding fresh into 2019
caught off of a blind smartphone camera
test win and a best battery life award
and probably the most well received
phone ever the mate 20 pro so now
incoming is the successor to their P 20
Pro and it's looking like it's gonna be
pretty promising and a lot of the same
ways now it still won't be in any US
carriers and it'll still be pretty
expensive but if you can look past those
two things it's looking like this may be
the first true galaxy s 10 competitor of
the year so that p 30 pro has three main
focuses camera design and specs but the
real focus the main one here is
definitely the new camera that's most of
what's new so let's just dive into that
first so as you can see it's rockin a
quad camera setup on the back so four
sensors on that back now and they all
have names to explain what's new and
what they do so the main camera is a 40
M a pixel sensor F 1.6 with oh is and
that's named the super spectrum camera
and it's called that because it has an R
yyb pattern array instead of the typical
RGB for the color filter in front of the
sensor and so the whole image stack is
redesigned around that which should let
about 40% more light hit that sensor
which means it's more light sensitive
than previous versions and Huawei told
me it can hit four times the ISO of the
last sensor up to 400 9600 so ideally
that should make for a pretty sweet
night mode then next up is the ultra
wide camera and that name is pretty
self-explanatory seems like it's all the
rage for 2019 smartphone cameras - if
you don't have that ultra wide and you
have multiple lenses what are you doing
and this one's a 20 megapixel ultra wide
with an F 2.2 aperture that pulls in a
more than 120 degree field of view so
yeah it's gone from a sort of a niche
thing that maybe only two phones had a
little while ago - kind of feeling like
you're missing out if you don't have it
so ultra wide is here then third I'm
gonna save the best for last the third
one is at the bottom it's the
time-of-flight lens which is mainly just
for depth information so that will help
with improved portrait mode better AR
experiences things like that
things that benefit from having great
depth mapping and then last but not
least is this square looking camera cut
out the big one that is the new
telephoto camera it's an 8 megapixel F
3.4 camera with oh is and the name for
that one is the periscope zoom lens now
you may notice with that square opening
it looks kind of strange so the reason
it's called a periscope camera is
literally the optics of this camera
instead of just going backwards go down
into the phone and then use a mirror to
face out so like like an actual
periscope so all of that to give you a
lossless 5 times optical zoom now the
number 5x might not be that impressive
but when you combine their optical
stabilization plus their AI enhanced ai
enhanced software stabilization you can
go way past 5x you can go to 10x 20x all
the way up to it'll let you hit 50 times
digital zoom which I'm gonna go ahead
and name super creep mode because 50
times zoom is absolutely insane I'm
trying it a bit outside and you know
you've been able to zoom in pretty far
for a while but it's crazy how far 50
times is and the most impressive part is
how good the stabilization is so my hand
is not super still this is just handheld
stuff and I'm moving around but the
compensation for my hand movement is
extreme so I don't know maybe for sports
events or concerts or I don't know one
would anyone need to zoom in this far
creepin on people and buildings blocks
away maybe I guess that is the benefit
of you know super creep mode for
periscope zoom on the p30 pro but also
keep in mind I haven't actually taken
any sample photos back with me yet so I
don't have much to judge by at this
moment I got to get it in hand and
actually test it for a review also the
autofocus seemed kind of jumpy with
close-up subjects so a little bit
finicky there so I don't know the
concept is really cool obviously but the
execution we'll have to see about
definitely make sure you subscribe for
the full review to see that when it
comes out but the rest of the p30 pro is
honestly incremental improvements and
check in all the boxes which is why I
can be seen as an s10 competitor so the
Twilight color of that p20 Pro was a hit
so they're doing a bunch more gradient
colors with this phone I'm gonna go
ahead and say this blue color called
aurora is the best-looking but there
will also be a amber sunrise
a pearl white a breathing crystal which
I also got hands-on with as you can see
and black the display is updated it's a
full screen six point four seven inch
OLED panel
23:40 by 1080 but instead of the chin
fingerprint reader from last year which
a lot of people forget about it's also
rocking an in display fingerprint reader
but it is optical again so not
ultrasonic so it'll still have all the
cons of optical that we discovered with
phones like the oneplus 60 like not
working when there's like debris on your
hands and having to shine a really
bright light at your finger to read it
but it did seem pretty fast to me when I
set it up with my finger so that's a
good sign so this tech is slowly getting
better and I think a few iterations in
it'll feel like a standard just not
quite yet also it has that cut top notch
at the top for the 32 megapixels selfie
camera it looks kind of like the
essential phone's notch a little more
curved but hey maybe the essential phone
was ahead of its time because Huawei's
now cut out all of those face ID sensors
they used to have in there much bigger
notch for just the camera and on the
specs our flagship grade Kirin 980 chip
a gigs of ram 4200 milliamp hour battery
which is huge it's IP 68 certified
there's now a faster er ofs file system
there's fast charging fast wireless
charging and it still has that
incredibly slow 2.5 watt troll mode
reverse wireless charging if you want to
use that honestly maybe the only thing
they can't say they have in this phone
is the headphone jack honestly though
that's a lot of boxes checked I'm really
into the battery I like that it's still
running emui
9.1 on top of Android Pi and in UI I've
said before not my favorite especially
with all the improvements Samsung's made
to their skin lately but just as a total
package p30 Pro clearly checks a lot of
boxes and that's what makes it exciting
also there will be a p30 non-pro that
will be a bit cheaper and just a bit cut
down with specs so it has three out of
the four cameras as you can see just
doesn't have the time of flight sensor
then it's a bit smaller too so it has a
6.1 inch non curved edge display pretty
flat a 3650 milliamp hour battery 6 gigs
of RAM instead of 8
IP 53 certified instead of ip68
but it's somehow gains room for a
headphone jack so there's that but what
do you think after seeing this is the
p30 pro a
worthy competitor 2's 10 plus I think
from my money the s 10 plus is still
gonna be the champ especially in the US
when it's in carrier stores and also a
bit cheaper but for those that are
really into cameras for those who want
to win all the blind smartphone camera
tests or if you have a habit of zooming
in obscenely far into all of your photos
you know this one might be worth a
second look either way that's been it
for the first impressions thanks for
watching catch you guys in the next one
peace thanks to LastPass for sponsoring
this hands-on video so we all know we
should be using a different secure
password for every different site we log
into but there's also no way to remember
20 plus different random passwords for
all the different logins you have so
that's where LastPass comes in you can
now have the security of multiple
passwords but the simplicity of only
having to remember a single master
password so don't worry about locking
accounts if you haven't signed into them
for months
or having to wait for a reset password
email only to enter a previously used
password so you can store all your
logins with LastPass and keep your
personal and business logins safe and
secure click the link below to get
LastPass for free